bring it on
that's the focus of tonight's angle
but importantly she says there is no
scientific debate when it comes to the
big picture there is no argument about
the value and the importance of gender
affirming care there is no argument
now forget her being a political
liability to the democrats you know
rachel levine
is first and foremost a liar
there's no argument among medical
professionals about subjecting minors to
this
complete barbarity well that's false
transition affirming therapies are
virtually untested and inflict lasting
harms
and instead of providing parents with
medical information and evidence-based
studies parents are frequently pressured
into accepting these risky treatments on
behalf of their children hasn't been
tested from childhood forward
medications are being used off label
without proper fda risk assessment
profile this whole thing is an
experiment on children
and let's drop the misleading euphemisms
gender affirming care goes beyond boys
wearing dresses and girls changing their
names
it can include barbaric surgery to
remove reproductive organs and hormones
to block puberty
now according to biden's hhs gender
affirming care includes social
affirmation at any age puberty blockers
during puberty and hormone therapy
starting during early adolescence
irreversible surgery
is quote typically used in adulthood
or
case by case in a case by case basis in
adolescence okay this is according to
hhs you know what i say what is a
case-by-case basis on what basis
are these exceptions made
for the adolescents to get this surgery
and i'm going to guess
it's a totality of circumstances test
meaning the language is vague enough to
allow for gender reassignment surgery on
demand regardless of the age
now parents across america are shocked
at the breakneck speed that basic truths
institutions are coming under assault
the united states we're talking about
what's happening at the court tonight
when they see a biological boy
playing women or girls in a sport
most parents are horrified they're
outraged
the same way that they feel when they
see schools pushing sex and gender
identity discussions on little kids
you took away my ability to parent my
child
even before i had any knowledge
i didn't even get to show support you
asked for support i didn't get a chance
your job was to educate my child in math
science english etc do your job and let
me do mine
it's a novel concept doing your job
yet the democrats seeing biden's numbers
cratering among almost every demographic
group they're determined to fight back
saw a little bit of that tonight at the
court don't you think
they've convinced themselves that
forcing their fringe ideas on the nation
no matter what they have to do to do
that will ultimately pay off and in the
meantime
they tar everybody else as outliers
holding back what is the proper progress
again as i mentioned tonight we learned
in this political piece that the court
has voted apparently to strike down roe
vs wade
coming from this leaked draft of an
opinion from the court which again is a
breach that has never occurred
in the history of the supreme court
and by the way the ruling
is just merely going to send the
abortion issue back to the states
the idea that the u.s constitution
ever prohibited states from regulating
or even outlawing if they deemed
appropriate the procedure
was total
legal fantasy from day one it was
totally made up
the left is going into the stratosphere
tonight they're going nuts
they know their entire facade everything
they fought for this is the die the the
hill that they'll die on they're worried
that it's all going to come crumbling
down
and they think that that somehow this
leak is going to be a gift that could
rescue them for the midterms
well the thinking is misguided
think about what the american people are
saying about some of the other hot
topics out there that were some of them
were discussing the gender identity push
and education of course the so-called
anti-racism ideology and crt influence
in schools how about the diversity
equity inclusion that's my favorite
acronym
the orthodoxy in college admissions
in corporate america
the attacks on law enforcement the
abortion industrial complex plot that's
screaming out tonight
trans athletes in women's sports
my five-year-old is being peddled
transgender books in her library
teenagers are being served pornography
under the guise of young adult
literature
do something be a leader
because if you know what the citizens of
this county deserve better
and as we saw at thursday's town hall in
orlando republican governors like ron
desantis are fighting back with success
even against some big corporations
so i want everyone to do well but i am
not comfortable having one company with
their own government and special
privileges when that company has pledged
itself to attacking the parents in my
state when that company
when that company
has very high up people
talking about injecting pansexualism
into programming for young kids it's
wrong walt disney would not want that
and so get back to the mission do what
you did great that's why people love the
company and you've lost your way maybe
this will be the wake-up call that they
need to get back on track
i never got a chance to see that uh
recorded that was pretty that's pretty
wild
but the white house think about that
they're fresh out of ideas
so what they've decided to do is to wind
up old biden and send them out to snap
back aggressively
today there are too many politicians
trying to score political points trying
to
ban books
even math books i mean did you ever
think even your younger teachers you
ever think
you'd be teaching you're going to be
worrying about book burnings and banning
books
all because it doesn't fit somebody's
political agenda we got to stop making
the target of the culture wars
maybe joe was sleeping over the past i
don't know 40 years
but his loyalists succeeded in removing
some of america's classic literary works
over that time books like huck finn
of mice and men
to kill a mockingbird
those are being taken out of school's
core curricula across the united states
so you got the teachers unions right
they're fighting not for great
literature but against any memory of
american traditionalism or excellence
even patriotism
and remember the american federation of
teachers it's biden's go-to cash cow
the unions by the way remember they did
more damage to children by supporting
the coveted lockdowns than we're ever
going to know
if they could remain virtual forever i
think they would have
if there are problems and shortages
then either some schools are closing in
those districts or those districts are
taking a pause it's not a matter of
we don't want to be there is that we
can't stay there testing mass
vaccinations
proper ventilation our schools
most of them don't have those basic
things
still waiting for that ventilation of
them to go back to work
over the weekend we were in florida and
then other parts which we'll talk about
later but
mothers fathers they were coming up to
us saying
never stop fighting for us please it's
always gratifying to hear from you
i had no idea frankly how bad things had
gotten with the schools until coveted
yet the biden administration is just
doubling down on their failure and
radicalism on all these cultural issues
and this means democrats are standing
against more traditional parents and
just common sense parents i think at
this point who just want politics out of
the classroom
but democrats they're finding some new
stars out there
so who am i i am a straight white
christian married suburban mom who knows
that the very notion that learning about
slavery or redlining or systemic racism
somehow means that children are being
taught to feel bad or hate themselves
because they are white is absolute
nonsense i want every child in this
state to feel seen heard and supported
not marginalized and targeted because
they are not straight white and
christian
the new yorker is calling her a role
model for the midterms i kid you not
move over aoc because a liberal karen
with a headband is coming for the
spotlight she's part joy reid part
gensake telling david remnick if
democrats don't stand up and fight back
the republicans are going to put forward
people who may not support our having
free and fair elections ever again she
hadn't heard about the court yet
now don't you love it though when
liberals spout these spurious concerns
about democracy one minute then they
support limiting free speech the next
and leaking stuff from the court
these people are the anti-democrats and
their thinking is as flat as their
singing
misinformation herself nina jankowicz
she's a rank partisan yet somehow she's
put in charge of the dhs disinformation
office
now guess what
misinformation called purveyors of
disinformation at the start of the
pandemic
okay those who question the ccp's
handling of covin were the ones pushing
out the disinformation according to her
that you know the whole wet market
origins theory that was ridiculous from
the beginning well it turns out her
commentary on kovid's origins
tracked china's remarkably well
again the lab leak theory is still the
most plausible explanation of kovit's
origins always has been
but tick-tock princess she doesn't care
don't hold your breath for fact checks
on china
the democrats new millennial culture
warrior will spend her time scolding
conservative media with a karaoke
accompaniment
tell any of this work
this in-your-face defense of the stuff
that they've been trying to hide from
parents and taxpayers for all these
years
these attacks on the first amendment
even now the supreme court's legitimacy
all i'll say is
republican campaign managers and their
candidates across america tonight
are thrilled about the democrats new
strategy
so bring it on
for too long the gop establishment has
run like scared little sisters from the
cultural issues those critical issues of
the day they prefer to focus on the safe
issues like economic and tax policy
that's not enough
not without the issues that touch the
formation of our children our own hearts
the sanctity of their bodies the safety
of our streets
the democrats have reminded us just how
critical these issues are
so let's hope the gop doesn't forget
those lessons
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else